هذه الكلمه التي يفترض ان يلقيها الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان من مقر حزب
العداله والتنميه في انقره هو ظهر قبل
قليل هذا المقر الذي كان يشهد احتفالات
الاسلام السوداء
ونحن في هذه الليله نعيش معا
البعض في المطبخ اما نحن في الشرفه
[موسيقى]
بسبب
ما شاء الله
شعبي العزيز
وايها المواطنون الذين يتابعوننا من خلال
شاشات التلفاز
وايها سكان
انقره وايها الاحباء والمؤيدين انني
احييكم جميعا بكل محبه وود
ان بلادنا من خلال الانتخابات في
14 مايو قد اثبتت ديمقراطيته
بكل بساله
وان كانت
النتائج غير النهائيه فاننا
متقدمون
ومتصدرون في هذه الانتخابات
بفارق شاسع
ومع
الانتهاء من فرز الاصوات بالداخل
ومع فرز اصوات الخارج وهذا ما سيتطلب وقتا
ربما
سنرى
انهم
سيحاولون الخداع
للشعب بالقول انهم هم متفوقون في واقي
الامر نحن لسنا كذلك نحن دائما كنا حياله
شعبنا
مصدقين وصادقين
وواقعين وانا اعلم باننا متفوقون
في هذه الانتخابات ولكن
نظرا لان النتائج الرسميه لم يتم الاعلان
عنها ننتظر ان تتجلى
الاراده الوطنيه وفي انتظار
النتائج
ان التقي بكم
لا القي خطابي من خلال هذه الشرفه وهذا
الخطاب الذي اعتدنا عليه
ما شاء الله
ما هذا
وما هذا
من الشوق يا له من حب ويا له من شوق ومحبه
من اسطنبول الى هنا الى انقره
والذين كانوا معنا في سير
وانتم الذين احتشدتم هنا وكل من يتابعوننا
ومن عملوا اليوم
كمراقبين
وموظفين في مراكز
التصويت
ومن تولى مهام في الخارج كلكم وكلهم
يستحقون كل التقدير والشكر
ولا شك
ان
الشكر الاكبر
لمواطنين الذين
تمسكوا
بالديمقراطيه من خلال الذهاب الى مراكز
التصويت
ومن كان
خيره في التصويت
لنا فهم كذلك توجهوا اليهم بجزيل الشكر
وكذلك
ان الفائز هو البلد بعيدا عن نتائج
الانتخابات في نهايه الامر والشعب هو
الفائز في واقي الامر
ان تركيا من خلال تمسكها
بالاراده الوطنيه وباراده الشعب
وبالاختيار الحر للمواطن قد اثبتت مره
اخرى انها تتصدر الدول
الديمقراطيه المتقدمه في العالم
[تصفيق]
الواقع تكشفه نسبه المشاركه في الانتخابات
تلك النسبه التي لا مثيل لها في العالم
نحن عشنا
نسبه
في المشاركه في تاريخنا السياسي
والحمد لله لم يحدث اي خلل او اي اختراق
في التصويت واتممنا ذلك
[موسيقى]
وايضا
والله هذا ما رايناه من خلال
اشراف اللجنه العليا الهيئه العليا
للانتخابات ايضا اخوتي
فان حزب الشعب الجمهوري
وبعضه رؤساء البلديات
[موسيقى]
بداوا يشككون في ذلك فان محاولاتهم
للتشكيك
لا تغير هذا الواقع
وان
تركيا تمتلك اليه اجراء انتخابات
مثاليه في العالم ولا يمكن لاحد ولا يحق
لاحد ان يلقي بالظلال على هذا الواقع ونحن
في تاريخنا السياسي دائما
كنا ولا نزال نحترم الاراده الوطنيه اي
نحترم ارادتكم انتم
ونحترم كذلك ارادتكم في هذا الانتخابات
وسنحترمها ايضا في الانتخابات القادمه
جمله
تحالف الجمهور
يعلم واجبه وقد
قمتم بالواجب اين
ونحن ننتظر من الجميع ابداع نفس النضج
الديمقراطي
وان الخلافات خلال الحمله الانتخابيه
قد
انتهت والكل
قدم ما بيده واليوم قرر الشعب
ولا معنى
لاتخاذ
ذرائع
[موسيقى]
تقديم مبررات
وهي ونحن سنرى
ايضا قرار الشعب النهائي
[تصفيق]
اخوتي واخواتي
مهما كانت نتيجه الانتخابات
[موسيقى]
يرمي يتيم مليونين يا قطه
اشكره 27 مليون مواطن قاموا بواجبهم
الديمقراطي من خلال المشاركه في التصويت
ومهما كان
قرارهم
وكذلك اشكر
56 مليون مواطن مره اخرى بغض النظر عن
اختياره
وايضا
وان الفارق بيننا وبيننا
المرشح الاقرب الينا هو اثنين مليون و600
الف صوت ومع
النتائج النهائيه انني اؤمن بان هذا
الفارق سيكون
اكبر من ذلك
وحسب
نظام الفوز في الانتخابات الذي هو خمسين
بالمئه زائد واحد نحن لا نعرفه هل
قسم ام لا
سنرى ان كان الشعب
يريد ان يحسم الامر في الجوله
الاولى وله ذلك واذا كان خيار الشعب ان
يحسم الامر في الجوله الثانيه على الراس
والعين ايضا ونحن نؤمن باننا سنكمل هذه
الجوله وسننتصر فيها بتحقيق خمسين بالمئه
زائد واحد لان
اصوات الخارج لم تصل الينا والتعداد مستمر
لذلك
انا
اطالب جميع الاخوه وجميع
المسؤولين في المسؤولين الحزبيين
ان يكونوا على يقظه وحتى يتم استكمال
التعداد كليا
ولا يانوا ولا يتراجع احد
في هذه المرحله ونحن سنتابع هذا الموضوع
عن كثب
ونجد ان نتائج الانتخابات البرلمانيه في
الوقت الراهن قبل النتائج النهائيه
بانها
تمثلت بالفوز لتحالف الجمهور
الان نجد ان تحالف الجمهور حقق الفوز
من حيث عدد النواب ومن حيث
عدد
اللجان البرلمانيه التي
ستتشكل في البرلمان
واعتقد ان هذا الشعب الذي
اختاره تحالف الجمهور في البرلمان لا شكه
ان خياره سيكون
للامن
والاستقرار والرفاهيه ايضا ونحن
كذلك
قطعنا بوعود من خلال جوالاتنا في الحمله
الانتخابيه
وحققنا ذلك ماذا قلنا هل تسمعون
انتم جاهزون قلنا
سنتحدث
الحمد لله
حققنا الوحده اليس كذلك
وقلنا سنكون اقوياء
الحمد لله
استطعنا ان نعزز بلدنا وحققنا القوه
وقلنا سنكون
على ثبات
والحمد لله من خلال ايضا
ازاله السحب
التي اطبقت على البلد في ظلالها استطعنا
ان نحقق الثبات وقلنا سنكون اخوه الم ندخل
في الانتخابات
بمشاركه كبيره انتبهوا هذه نقطه مهمه لم
نكون مع الارهابيين
نحن
لم نكن مع من كان سببا في مقتل اخوتنا
الاكراد في ديار بكر
ونحن كذلك لم نكون مع هؤلاء الذين
قالوا هم من قتلت الاطفال الصغار
ومن قالوا باننا سنكسر ابواب سجون لاطلاق
السراح الارهابيين واخوتي الاعزاء نحن
نتلقى تعليماتنا من الله ومن هذا الشعب
وقلنا نحن معا
سنمثل تركيا
نحن
مع
جميع المواطنين
الساكنين في الولايات التركيه الواحده
والثمانين استطعنا ان نحقق الوحده
كانت النتائج النهائيه غير صادره ولكن
هناك واقع ان الشعب معنا باغلبيه ساحقه
وسنقول كذلك ما كنا نقوله هل انتم جاهزون
[تصفيق]
سنتحد
سنتحدث
[تصفيق]
نقوى
سنحقق الثبات
سنكون اخوه
جميعا سنمثل تركيا
ومن هذا المنطلق
ان اؤمن بانني ساخدم هذا البلد خلال
الولايه القادمه
لمده خمس سنوات
لا
شكري تباري له سياسي
شهدنا في تاريخنا السياسي انتخابا متميزا
جدا
[تصفيق]
نعم من عاش وراى هذه الانتخابات
فليذكر لاطفالهم واجدادهم كيف ان تركيا
تجاوزت كل هذه العقبات وحققت مئويه تركيا
كن صامدا فان تركيا معك
يرن برقم مقصد ومن اجله
تتعبر خطواتنا في طريق التقدم والازدهار
ايضا سنسير سويا وذلك من اجل الحفاظ على
وحده واخوتي شعبنا
وكذلك هدى
تذكرون للاجيال القادمه تلك الملحمه التي
نقوم نحن بتدوينها معاكم
واليوم جبر اتفاق
انا
اخاطب الجميع اعضاء
جارتني تبارك
الجمهور
واخاطب الشعب برمته ايضا
وانه
سنبدا بالعمل من اجل التحقيق
امل هذا الشعب
والشعوب دون
لايستفزازات والوقوع فيها سنعمل سنبذل
جهودا كبيرا من اجل نيله رضا الشعب فحسب
وذلك بهدف
بناء تركيا الكبيره تركيا العظيمه لا
تشكوا انه لا يستطيع احد ان يعرقل تركيا
وان يتصدى لتركيا في تحقيق
مئويتها ايضا وانا اتمنى ان تكون نتائج
الانتخابات عائده بالخير على تركيا
واتمنى لكم
امسيه جميله دمتم بامان
[موسيقى]